For obvious reasons, we don't know what or if a fetus is thinking inside its
mother's womb. But we do know a lot about what infants think. In fact, we know
a lot about the development of cognitive abilities across the lifespan from
Swiss psychologist Jean Piaget. Piaget argued for distinct stages of
development across the lifespan. The first stage he termed the sensory motor
stage. Infants lack verbal behavior. They cannot think about the past and they
can't plan for the future, therefore they live very much in the present moment.
In the here and now. However, they do interact with their world. They use their
five senses. They can see, touch, taste, smell, and hear, and they use these
senses to make sense of their world. This is what Piaget meant by the sensory
part of sensory motor stage.